FULL-FLEDGED INVESTIGATION
TONIGHT AND WE WILL SHOW YOU
MORE OF THAT.
WE BEGIN WITH TONIGHT’S BIG
BREAKING NEWS.
IT’S THE MOMENT WE HAVE BEEN
ANTICIPATING FOR A LONG TIME ON
THIS SHOW.
EQUAL JUSTICE, EQUAL APPLICATION
OF OUR LAWS.
ECHO FLYNN WAS A WAR HERO, HE
SERVED THIS COUNTRY HONORABLY
AND WITH DISTINCTION.
WITH MULTIPLE TOURS OF IRAQ AND
AFGHANISTAN HE PUT HIMSELF IN
HARM’S WAY FOR FREEDOM UNDER WAY
OF LIFE.
33 YEARS OF TOTAL SERVICE, HE
WAS UNJUSTLY TARGETED BY
DEEP STATE BUREAUCRATS THAT
CLEARLY, WITH ALL THE EVIDENCE
TO PROVE IT, WANTED TO TAKE HIM
DOWN.
WE HAVE UNSEALED DOCUMENTS TO
PROVE THAT CORRUPT AGENTS FROM
JIM COMEY’S FBI WERE DISCUSSING
STRATEGIES ON HOW TO SET
GENERAL FLYNN UP ON WHAT WE CALL
A PERJURY TRAP.
ACCORDING TO ONE HANDWRITTEN
NOTE, AN UNNAMED AGENT ASKED,
WHAT IS OUR GOAL HERE?
IS IT TRUTH?
ADMISSION?
OR TO GET HIM TO LIVE?
TO GET HIM TO LIVE, IS THAT OUR
GOAL?
WE CAN PROSECUTE HIM OR GET HIM
FIRED.
IT IS AT THE FBI’S ROLE?
AT THIS, IN A EMAIL PETER STRZOK
AND HIS FBI LOVER LISA PAGE
DISCUSS HOW TO CASUALLY SLIP IN
AN ADMONITION ABOUT LYING UNDER
OATH IN ORDER TO SET A PERJURY
TRAP.
THESE AGENTS WERE PREPARING FOR
AN INTERVIEW THAT ULTIMATELY DID
TAKE PLACE ON JANUARY 24TH,
2017.
THEY WARNED THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION, TRUTH BE TOLD IT
WAS AN AMBUSH.
A LEGAL ABUSE OF POWER.
DURING THE PHONE CALL IT WAS
McCABE WHO RECOMMENDED TO
FLYNN, YOU DON’T NEED TO HAVE AN
ATTORNEY DURING THE INTERVIEW,
THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN A MIRANDA
RIGHTS VIOLATION.
FOUR DAYS AFTER
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S INAUGURATION,
PETER STRZOK AND ONE OTHER AGENT
VISITED THE WHITE HOUSE AND THEY
WERE THERE TO INTERROGATE FLYNN.
THEY WERE SENT BY JIM COMEY
HIMSELF.
JAMES COMEY BRAGGING, HE SENT
THE AGENTS TO GRILL HIM FOR TWO
DAYS.
HE WANTED TO EXPLOIT THE CHAOS
INSIDE THE TRANSITIONING
WHITE HOUSE.
SOMETHING HE WOULD NEVER DO IN
THE BUSH OR OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION’S COME OR GET
AWAY WITH.
ULTIMATELY THAT PERJURY TRAP WAS
NOT A SUCCESS.
AGENTS ARE NO INDICATION AT ALL
THAT THE NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISOR WAS LYING.
THEY DIDN’T BELIEVE HE WAS
LYING.
THEY SAID HE DIDN’T BELIEVE HE
WAS LYING.
THE FBI TURN THE SCREWS ANYWAY,
THEY THREATEN TO LOCK HIM UP FOR
YEARS.
EVENTUALLY HE WENT BANKRUPT.
HE HAD TO SELL HIS HOME.
THEY THREATEN TO PROSECUTE HIS
SON.
THEY ULTIMATELY FORCED HIM TO
PLEAD GUILTY, GET THIS GUILTY
PLEA, OR THEY WERE GOING TO
PROSECUTE HIS SON.
THEY DIDN’T THINK HE LIED, BUT
THEN THEY FORCED HIM TO LIVE,
CORE STEM INTO MAKING
STATEMENTS.
WHY?
TO PROTECT HIS SON.
FRANKLY, WHAT A GREAT FATHER
WOULDN’T DO THAT?
EITHER YOU SIGN THIS OR WE WILL
PUT YOUR SON WAY FOR THE REST OF
HIS LIFE.
WHERE DO I SIGN?
HE WAS SET UP, A PERJURY TRAP
ALL ALONG.
COMEY FBI KNEW THE RUSSIA
COLLUSION NARRATIVE AND THEY
KNEW IT WAS A HOAX.
WE HAVE NEW INFORMATION
REGARDING THAT.
THEY WERE HELL-BENT TO PUNISH
ANYONE INSIDE THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
BY THE WAY, MR. COMEY I’VE BEEN
WARNING YOU.
YOU HAVE THE RIGHT TO REMAIN
SILENT.
I SUGGEST YOU USE IT.
YOU’VE NOT LISTEN TO ME.
JIM, TICK TOCK.
KEEP IN MIND WE’VE BEEN RIGHT
EVERY STEP OF THE WAY AND THE
MEDIA MOB HAS LIED, ADVANCED
HOAX AFTER HOAX, CONSPIRACY
THEORY AFTER CONSPIRACY THEORY.
THE SOCIALIST PAPER OF RECORD OF
UNITED STATES.
THE NEW YORK TOILET PAPER TIMES.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THIS IS WEEK ONE OF THE TRUMP
PRESIDENCY.
IT IS THE NAME OF JIM COMEY’S
BOOK, "HIGHER LOYALTY?"
WOULDN’T THAT BE THE
UNITED STATES CONSTITUTION, DOES
THAT SOUND LIKE A VIRTUOUS
PUBLIC SERVANT TO YOU?
OR SOMEONE TRYING TO TRAP
LIEUTENANT GENERAL FLYNN PEERED
FROM DAY ONE.
>> PAGE AFTER PAGE OF EVIDENCE,
CORRUPT AGENTS LIKE McCABE AND
PETER STRZOK COMEY AND OTHERS
WERE CONSPIRING TO SET
GENERAL FLYNN UP AND RUIN HIS LI
AND BY THE WAY THIS IS EXHIBIT A
OF A CORRUPT BUREAUCRACY THAT
IS A THREAT TO EVERYTHING WE
HOLD DEAR.
OUR REPUBLIC IS NOW, AND I’M NOT
OVERSTATING THIS, WE ARE FACING
A CLEAR AND PRESENT DANGER.
AMERICAN IS AT A TIPPING POINT.
WE’VE BEEN VERY IMPORTANT
ELECTION IN 188 DAYS.
TO THE CREDIT OF THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL BELLA BAR, HE
HAS BEEN LEAVING THESE LITTLE
CRUMBS
HERE, THEY ARE, AND EVERYWHERE
AND IF YOU LISTEN TO WHAT HE IS
SAYING, THE PRESIDENT WAS SPIED
ON, THE CANDIDATE WAS SPIED ON.
HE HAS MADE OTHER STATEMENTS
LIKE, THIS IS NOT ABOUT WRITING
A PAPER, THIS IS ABOUT JUSTICE.
THIS, MY SOURCE TELLS ME IS ALL
HAPPENING BECAUSE THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL BELIEVES IN THE
RULE OF LAW.
BY THE WAY, I HAVEN’T FBI PIN
HERE AND I HAVE A CIA PEN HERE.
WHY?
FOR THE 99% THAT DO A GREAT JOB
AND PROTECT US EVERY DAY.
WE MUST RESTORE CONFIDENCE IN
OUR PREMIER ENFORCEMENT AGENCY.
THE PREMIER INTELLIGENCE AGENCY
IN THE WORLD.
FOR THE SAKE OF OUR
CONSTITUTION, FOR THE SAKE OF
THE 99% OF PEOPLE WHO BRAVELY
SERVE THESE INSTITUTIONS AND
PROTECT US.
THANKS TO THE PRESIDENT AND HIS
ATTORNEY GENERAL BELLA BAR, THIS
DEEP STATE RECKONING IS GOING ON
RIGHT BEFORE OUR EYES.
IT’S SAD TO SEE, BUT AT LEAST
PEOPLE BELIEVE IN THE LAW.
THIS IS NOT HOW WE SHOULD BE
TREATING A 33 YEAR DEVOTED
VETERAN WHO LOVES HIS COUNTRY